Peter Schrager NFL Network good morning
football co-host although there's four
of you yeah
can you be a co-host with four no but
are you the coho is it you and Kay Adams
who are co-hosting I feel like I'd say
I'm like the fourth Beatle I'm more like
Pete best out there why I chime in once
in a while over there though there this
though are you still doing sidelines
doing sidelines and I'm doing studio for
Fox I'm alternating Sundays so I'm gonna
be in the studio in LA this weekend
which should be fun and then then you'll
do a sideline I'm doing Chiefs Niners
week three Arrowhead opener which I'm
excited for because suddenly they're a
fun team to watch I was also wondering
about this I just mentioned it to
McLovin that that Prescott went from a
steel this unbelievable fine we got our
franchise quarterback you got a guy not
making a lot of money we can you know
spread the money around we got a chance
to go back to the Super Bowl now all of
a sudden we're wondering if he's a
franchise quarterback it's an amazing
conversation what's interesting is the
fourth round pick which means he can
negotiate his contract after this season
Goffin Wentz can't they have to wait for
another year before they can get that
availability to do that which means
Jerry's kind of gotta decide right now
on DAC and that's that kind of
controlling his own destiny and one week
into it if I'm Jerry Jones am i throwing
25 million dollars at what I saw last
week or let's go to the drawing board
again let's get another guy it's really
interesting cuz not only would see the
NFL Offensive Player of the Year appear
he was the face of the Dallas Cowboys
and you look at generational guys
Aikman Romo he was that guy this week is
a huge game at home national TV NBC the
whole thing if the Cowboys offense falls
on its face again people are gonna start
being stop being so nice to that
Prescott do you think he's a franchise
quarterback I don't know yet I don't
know yet he had the most wins out of any
NFC quarterback over the first two years
the last two years and yet I'm still not
sure whether he's that guy well this is
this a different era if this was when
Bart Starr was you know quarterbacking
the Packers or Bob Griese was
quarterbacking the Miami Dolphins you
could manage a game now we want to know
what kind of stats you have and dak
Prescott were waiting for those stats
and we haven't seen it in the last nine
games who hasn't thrown for 200 yards
know it's wild and you know you look at
it
Paxton Lynch was drafted before him
Connor Cook was draft before him
everyone said oh what idiots what idiots
but the evaluation out of college no one
had dak Prescott as a first or second
round pick so now there's this
revisionist history of wait a second
is he that great or was that just the
ideal situation with the offensive line
the running back and of course des in
Witten on the field
none of those wide receiver step w the
last week it was Linehan had a bad game
we've seen quarterbacks come out and
have great first years in the NFL and
then kind of taper off I've heard RG
three's name being mentioned there are
some others I think dak is the ultimate
teammate he's the ultimate face for
franchise but for cowboys fans in that
market I think a 5 and 11 season is
unacceptable right now if I said which
quarterback won't be with his respective
team in two years and I gave you Jameis
Winston Marcus Mariota Derek Carr Jack
Prescott it's tough because all of those
teams have general managers who drafted
those guys so they're kind of invested
in them they want them to work out you
don't want to get another one I the one
that's so interesting to me is Prescott
because of what we're going through here
in Dallas with this big changing of the
guard and if Jason Garrett's back next
year I think dad will be back but again
if this season hits the skids and
they're 3 and 13 or they're 4 and 12 I
don't think anyone safe what would you
do if you're the Packers with Aaron
Rodgers is it up to him or is it up to
your medical staff they have the most
cautious the most responsible medical
staff in the end if I'd seen Scott toll
zine start multiple games where Rodgers
wanted to play if they're giving him the
okay I'm going with Aaron Rodgers
because this is a huge divisional game
you got a win gotta beat the Vikings at
home and Aaron Rodgers gives you the
best chance to win
if I'm the Packers I am playing Aaron
Rodgers if he has given the medical ok
what if he wants to play but they're the
medical clearance is not there I don't
know that that one's tough and I think
everybody in America would say well you
trust the doctors but you're Aaron
Rodgers is a gamer man and I don't think
any other quarterback necessarily we've
been out there last week and they
wouldn't won that game with any other
quarterback I wonder if the medical team
cleared him to play in the second half
he was out there I know I know I know
I wonder because I think there's damage
in that knee now that the question is
how severe is the damage and I don't
believe this when they say well you
can't do further damage well you can't
okay look at Ryan Tannehill last year
the same exact thing happened but you
know it's funny because you saw it's one
thing I've done sidelines for years it's
one thing when the guy goes under the
tent when they get on the cart it's over
the cart is undefeated when the guy gets
on the cart he's holding his knee
goodbye I'll see you next year and then
Tafoya comes out at halftime and it's
like a buh buh and Aaron Rodgers is
gonna pull Mike whoa I've never seen a
guy go on the cart hold his knee tears
in his eyes and then 30 minutes in real
time be ready to lead his team back I
don't know if it was miraculous I don't
know if it was just me going to an
immediate dark place thinking we lost
Rodgers or if it was just adrenaline but
that performance it might be forgotten
two weeks from now I'll never forget
what he just did because that was
incredible and I think if they could do
that I can win any game I think he can
play against the Vikings and get it done
I still wonder if he would have gone out
for the second half if he had not signed
that big contract interesting it's
interesting i Michael's had a great
comment it was late in though he goes if
it's 24 nothing to even bring him back
even if he can it's even out there the
answer is who cares he went out there
and he played he got the contract it did
it all he's got the weight of the city
behind him he's got that whole franchise
behind him I know it's a long season but
this might be their most important game
week two at home against the defending
champions who knocked him out last year
okay what is must-see TV the one game if
you could only watch one game this
weekend Chiefs vs. Steelers I'm
fascinated by my homes the Steelers beat
Steelers beat the Chiefs three times in
a row and each time Andy Alex Smith just
could not get it going like it was
thinking dunk and they didn't have the
big shot to Tyreke the Steelers own the
Chiefs in recent history and yet they
have this giant X Factor where the
quarterback that can stretch the field
and if the Steelers go Oh 1 in 1 the
levian question starts throwing up again
the Bengals are now undefeated and who
knows what we're gonna get moving
forward from the Browns like that game
is fascinating because the Chiefs put a
whooping on the Chargers in their
building and now they're gonna go into
another AFC powers building and I think
they might do the same can the Steelers
get to the Super Bowl without Le'Veon
Bell yes yes they can but it's gonna
take a lot more than if they didn't have
him on I mean he is that good
I think he's Fenton James Conner played
great last week but that was a Steelers
team who was up 14 points in the fourth
quarter against the Browns everyone's
patting the Browns on the back and
saying great job
the sealers were up 14 on the Browns and
couldn't close the door that worries me
a little bit well also been I I just
don't know if there's another
quarterback who you can say he can throw
four touchdowns or throw four
interceptions like what are the
quarterback comes to mind elite
quarterback I was gonna say there's one
yeah but but here's a Hall of Fame
quarterback yeah I guess you could say
Eli Marvin Eli right like Favre used to
throw a lot of pics yeah then it's you
know quarter to quarter with him he can
have three amazing plays and then it's
three boneheaded plays you're like
what's going on
Steelers are pretty thin man I mean it's
like James Conner played great last week
JooJoo played well in Antonio Brown
played well but if you look offense and
defense aside from maybe cam Hayward and
a couple other guys on that d their
roster is not bustling with young talent
it's like they're waiting for guys to
step up sealers Chiefs this week is a
very interesting game Chiefs have been
embarrassed by the Steelers I want to
see if they can return the favor and
also you have tweeted out already that
we should be jumping on the Ben goals
bandwagon if it was the two-and-oh
Ravens then we would be shouting from
the mountaintops that they're back and a
playoff Super Bowl contender why are we
not acknowledging the bengals because of
just our own ingrained history with the
bengals i think if you looked
objectively at their first two games
they scored 34 points in both games they
were in the lead late in both those
games and closed the door and their
quarterback played as well as the other
quarterback who was it was Andrew Luck
and Joe Flacco I think objectively you
would say the bengals are a team to be
reckoned with but because it's the
bengals people want to wait until
january which whether fair or not it is
what it could be 15 and one going to the
playoffs and the majority the country's
gonna pick against them in that first
game well they haven't earned our trust
it's fair objectively they played
amazing football if the Ravens had won
that game last night and the Ravens were
two-and-oh with that defense I think
we'd be doing flips saying well the
Ravens I remember Joe Flacco was gonna
fire fire lit under him this year
objectively the bengals put a whooping
on the Ravens last night and no one's
talking around this morning and no one
will until January when they have to
actually win the division to get our
respect and they win a playoff game
yeah win a playoff game Wow Peter
Schrager NFL Network good morning
football co-host Fox sports.com senior
national writer as well the importance
of the New England Jacksonville game is
what it's
big it's big because Jaguars won a game
in New York that people were like all
right there were three and thirteen last
year the Giants are gonna be pretty good
this year that was a big win but this
one is the first game in conference and
it's against the guys that beat you in
it kind of sets the tone if you go to a
no beat and the Giants in New York and
you beat the Patriots I think it's a
message to the rest of the league last
year's run was cool it was great
everything you've got to do it again so
to me if the jaguars can beat the
Patriots and do it the way Jaguars win
games which is low-scoring beat the snot
out of the other quarterback and set the
tone I think there's a message and for
those young Jaguars defenders we're
talking the telev in Smith's and the
jail and Rams on it to get one of these
teams and win and you know the Steelers
is one thing but to beat the Patriots
after all this week of build-up it says
a lot you all in on the Rams
I am I I'm talking historic offense and
really good defense all in on the RAM do
you think the offense is better than the
- yes he Shawn McVeigh showed a little
bit of his playbook on Monday night that
was almost like he called off the dogs
when it got late but I know they were
losing at halftime but all those little
handoff to the wide receivers Cooper the
first drive of the game they're handing
the ball off the Cooper Cup and they did
it next to Brandon cooks and they did it
next Robert woods that's just scratching
the surface his playbook is so big and
so diverse and no one has seen anything
of it because I didn't play in the
preseason I I think this offense this
week is gonna put up another huge number
the Rams are legit and until there's
injuries because their depth is not
great till there's injuries I don't see
anyone maybe the Vikings defense week
for I don't see anyone in the near
future really putting it to him but I
also look at Jared Goff I think this is
all on Jared Goff I think that he is
carrying an inordinate amount of
pressure because your defense is sent
yep your offense has skilled position
guys yep you got a good offensive line
defensive flow comes down to and the
best play caller yeah maybe outside of
Sean Payton Visser's this is Jared Goff
right right isn't it funny it's a very
similar situation in Chicago right now
yes I said the same thing that you make
the deal for Khalil Mack you're saying
to your fan base Mitchell true Biscay a
franchise quarterback they hired Matt
naggy who's an offensive minded coach
they hired Helfrich to give a little
that college fielding at all those play
Rams and bears although the Rams have
already had some success and they're
their quarterback situations are very
interesting because you want to go the
next level with it golf was taken before
Carson wins
and true Biscay was taken before my
Holmes and Watson so not only they all
in they also made a decision in that
draft room to say we're so all in that
we took him over these other guys that
look like they were sure bets and
everyone else thought they were too
I think off is the real deal I think
he's really good I think he's really
helped by having a great head coach and
really good skill position players
around him Seattle has signed Michael
Kendricks who was released by the Browns
he's pled guilty to insider trading he's
going to prison and Seattle picked him
up and probably gonna play against the
Bears on Monday night should the
Commissioner be involved in this it's
like a big big picture if they like
white-collar crime like where do we come
down on this right like I feel like all
crimes should be created equally and
he's going to prison and the justice
system is going to it's a really tough
thing to swear up in arms over domestic
violence and rightfully so but those
guys don't go to prison no this is
insider trading where you're going to
prison fascinating case study and the
NFL still has not waited on it so I know
let's see before Sunday because if he's
out there Monday night against the Bears
on Monday Night Football and Michael
Kendricks makes 13 tackles has two sacks
in an interception at some point Jason
Witten needs to coffee and say yeah he
also is going to jail for insider
trading which is also not a good look
the NFL has enough things going on with
all this stuff that this is the last
thing any as this guy on the field that
said he's not in prison what about the
commissioners exempt list they could put
him on that they did that a lot of times
they did that for several players Josh
brown one of them like let's wait and
see let's kind of see where we're at
with this just put his number under like
hit zero four nine six nine three four
and when they put him up on the screen
and introduce him do you have the Hall
of Fame question yes there's a NFL is
less there modern-era nominees for the
Hall of Fame of these five guys they
have in the picture you could only give
your vote to one of the five john lynch
tony gonzalez ed Reed Champ Bailey Hines
Ward you only get to pick one great
question you want me to answer mine I'm
going Tony Gonzalez he's the greatest to
ever play the position not named Gronk
I'm gonna go Tony G you think Gronk will
recognises a better tight end than Tony
when it's all done mm-hmm yeah he's not
gonna stay healthy enough long enough
and there's also gonna be the question
of was it Brady and Belichick and
McDaniels that helped make wrong I think
Tony Gonzales the greatest I tend to
ever play the game and I think I left
that Gronk caveat because there's still
a potential of five more years
if healthy he could beat those numbers
but Tony can Ed Reid and Tony Gonzales
my guys but Tony Gonzalez to me best to
ever play his position that's where I'm
going on that one yeah I could I think
Champ Bailey is underrated John Lynch's
come close here Hines Ward is gonna get
in I think it comes down to ed Reed ed
Reed was a playmaker Offensive Player of
the Year from the safety position would
you rather have Edie Reed or Ray Lewis
it's a great question probably go ray I
feel like Ray like birthed that defense
like that was raised and ed Reed carried
the torch but like I'm not sure that
defense is that defense in the early
2000s without Ray Lewis showing and read
the way that's a political answer but I
love both of them well I think Rod
Woodson showed ed Reed the way rate
comment and people forget how great I
think Rod Woodson you could make a case
is the best athletes who ever play a
defensive position he was he could have
been an Olympic hurdler
safety corner and kick ass he was
incredible any tackled people you know
was good at cover and he had how many
interceptions did he have he has the
most interceptions taken for a touchdown
in the history game in today Rod Woodson
tangent played in a Super Bowl on a torn
ACL came back that you shut down Michael
Irvin yeah amazing
did you see Steve Smith and Michael
Irvin go back and forth I did and I
don't I'm not gonna speak out of school
I don't I don't think that was for show
guy no I don't think it I feels like
Steve Smith may have a sense of humor
but then he may not and depending on
when you say something so Michael Irvin
has a sense humor we know that yes but
but Mike says something and then all of
a sudden Steve says something and it
feels like with it this is on now he's
like saying you know I got it like a
master's degree in route running
you've got a bachelor's from a community
college I have a doctorate in route
running unit and look Steve Smith if you
want to go through the careers has more
yards more reception awesome butter fine
I'm curious colleen wolf was the host I
thought she handled it very well on that
how would you have handled that would
you have made a made a big joke out of
it would you have tried to spur it up
even more it was captivating TV I'm not
sure it was comfortable TV what would
you have done I think the fact that it
was real and it's live and in that
moment then go for it if we did that and
we were taping something I might have
somebody say no I don't want to put that
out there I think looking at the content
part of it I would have said Steve what
is your problem with Mike because you
can't just go alright we'll be back
after that like you just okay he just
said that and you can see where Mike is
looking at him like are you are we
seriously yeah yeah yeah I got three
rings and then it becomes this whole
conversation about their careers when
there's a game going on background
what's interesting about it is I've had
Steve Smith we've had Steve Smith on our
show but I've had a lot of interaction
Steve Smith on TV he'll go at it and
into the drop of it like we had a absurd
debate that got really heated and I
defended my turf but then afterwards we
hugged it out and all that but I said
Josh Rosen has no right to be upset
being drafted 10th overall if he was
undrafted or somebody that this is at
the draft and Steve to his credit comes
in he's like I was a third-round pick
but I think anytime you were passed over
by someone else there's a chip on your
shoulders not matter where and when and
who's is the best yeah but he's 10
things I make 22 million this year he's
very crying about it's like you don't
know how he feels and it was this thing
where like Steve Smith is very
passionate I think it makes for great TV
and I don't know if they read on the
joke out of the dog whatever having
spoken either one of the guys I didn't
stop watching I don't think that there
was a joke there but I would have read
one more time I would like to have just
seen where we were going if we were
gonna escalate or we were gonna try to
take the air out of the been in a
situation like that with 200 us I'm sure
I have like one of the stranger moments
was I was at this Stanley Cup final and
Chicago and Philadelphia Jeremy Roenick
started crying cuz he's so happy for
Chicago well Chicago won and then he
started crying and then he he just
couldn't get it together
because he thought you know what I never
want to stand worked up so he just when
we got done we're done with the show and
he stood up and was just staring back at
the ice so we're leaving we're leaving
the building
this is fascinating Jeremy is just
standing there looking down at the ice
and nobody said anything to him I just
said hey you know we're gonna go he
didn't say anything but in that moment I
had even though he's crying the audience
has to know why you're crying like what
do you well why is this affecting you
yes and then he starts to talk about
that Ron Jaworski came on the day after
the Super Bowl when the Eagles won and
he started crying and and I when I said
to him you do you rely I mean is it sunk
in the Eagles have won the Super Bowl
and he got so emotional but I don't want
to I don't want to I know you're
vulnerable and I don't want to over I
don't want to make this about me and
yeah overdramatize this yes but I just
want to I had to judge let me extract
what I can out of this that makes it
seem like I am sensitive to you but also
this is good TV that Ron Jaworski is
crying because the Eagles have won is
Super Bowl what can I make you cry
what'll make you cry too easy I don't
know talk about any ending of any movie
I've seen on a flight in the last five
years I really yeah I cried at the movie
the intern with that fantastic in it no
she's not
fantastic he's so bad not only is the
job she also saves a marriage it was
incredible huh is it a documentary no
it's just a beautiful love story between
man woman and intern okay I cried I
cried at Book of Mormon did you yes
because it was so amazing like you were
so everyone with the the acting and
everything I was live like I Springsteen
came out saw him last Friday night you
think I really liked it yeah but when he
came out and started playing growing up
I started crying yeah it Mike said to my
wife I said you know how I'm gonna cry
when Springsteen comes out you let the
opening song yeah right away yeah he
just he just comes out and boom and then
starts telling a story but Book of
Mormon which is really funny hilarious
intermission lights come on and my kids
are going why are you crying you think
it was because I just watching somebody
do something live there's something
about when you have to do it and that's
why I always put even more pressure on
myself when I was handing out the Super
Bowl trophy it's live it's right there
that I get it I don't get another take
there's a hundred million people
watching and you've got to get in do it
and get out and do it right and it's not
easy and so you're in that moment of
it's live and I just I have great
respect when I buy a Broadway show now
you told Trey and Mad Men and the guys
who created Book of Mormon you should
know you should let them discuss from
South Park they did that yeah you should
tell them that's a great story well we
were in BASEketball together did you cry
it BASEketball of course I do
all right it's great to see you I love
being you have a great weekend
he's an NFL Network co-host a good
morning football I guess like you're one
of the stars did this because you're a
co-host I'm one of the cause yeah you
and Kay Adams are the co-hosts of good
morning football were the Coase and Nate
Burleson and Kyle brayer there's a long
list of us I'm Dorothy but are they
co-host I don't know if you identify
them as co-hosts oh I don't know when we
had Nate in last week um co-host I did
not call him a co-host I think I said
contributor to a good morning football
it's got a doctorate and route running
too you know he does good runner yeah
he's a great talent too it's a great
show
thank you NFL Network good morning
football Peter Schrager for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]